Speaker 1: We start today, not with a profile
in courage, but with a profile in cowardice. And
the guy's name is Ron DeSantis. Ron DeSantis
has come up with the most squirrely. I mean,
we're talking nuttier than squirrel poop.
Excuse the metaphor, the squirrel iest way to
avoid answering a very simple question did failed
twice, indicted, twice impeached former President
Donald Trump violate the peaceful transfer of
power, which was almost, I guess we could say
they tried to stop on January six, 2021. And
Ron DeSantis comes up with an answer that is,
it's so stupid, it's almost laughable. And
something very strange is going on with my hair,
as you can see. And I really do apologize
to the audience for that continued issues.
He says, I wasn't in Washington, DC on
January 6th, so I don't really know what
happened. Oh, we did.
Speaker 2: Well.
Speaker 1: We'll get back to that. Well,
take a listen to this. Do you believe.
Speaker 3: That Trump violated the peaceful
transfer of power, a key principle that of
American democracy that we must uphold?
Speaker 4: Are you in high school?
Yeah. Where do you go to school? You go around
here? Vermont. I live in New Hampshire. Oh,
okay. So you run from. Right? Well, thank you
for the question. So. Well, here's what I know.
If this election is about Biden's failures and
our vision for the future, we are going to win.
If it's about relitigating things that happened
to three years ago, we're going to lose. And so.
Speaker 1: By the way, all Ron DeSantis is doing
is relitigating COVID and talking about how he
was so much better than Trump on COVID.
So even even he's already lying. But then
we're getting to the real whopper.
Speaker 4: I can tell you this.
Speaker 1: Tell us why the sanctimonious.
Speaker 4: I can tell you this. I can point you
to Tallahassee, Florida, on, I believe, January
5th, 2023. We had a transition of power from my
first administration to my second because I.
Speaker 1: Noticed that this is completely
unrelated to the question.
Speaker 4: On reelection in
a historic fashion. And at the end of the day,
you know, we need to win and we need to get this
done. So I wasn't anywhere near Washington that
day. I have nothing to do with what happened that
day. Obviously, I didn't enjoy seeing, you know,
what would happen. But we've got to go forward.
Speaker 1: Remember, the question wasn't were
you in D.C. or did you have anything to do with
it? The question was, will you actually denounce
what Donald Trump did? It's a cowardly copout to
say I didn't enjoy seeing what happened. Well,
Ron didn't enjoy it and I didn't enjoy it. But
I'm willing to say Trump was at least partially
responsible for what took place by inciting his
followers. Ron DeSantis isn't willing to say
that this is the I hate to use the term the
Trump term. This is a low energy, cowardly way to
run a campaign. If you're actually going to make
the case that you're the better choice than Trump
on all fronts. You're going to say, I never would
have said the things Trump said because any
sensible person would realize how some of his
followers would take it. And I wouldn't want that
responsibility on my shoulders. I will govern in
a different way. I would never do such a thing.
And by the way, I'm also better on policy. But
instead, DeSantis knows he sees the numbers. This
is all a numbers game in order to have a shot.
At winning the primary. DeSantis knows he either
needs to dramatically increase Republican primary
turnout, which just doesn't seem like it's going
to happen. Or he needs to take some of Trump's
current support because Trump's already polling
52% and DeSantis is calculating. I can't take
Trump's support from his hardcore supporters
by saying he was responsible for the riots. I
can't do it. It's not going to work. So instead,
DeSantis is taking the cowardly way out, saying he
didn't like what happened and that people should
vote for him. And if Trump gets indicted a third
or fourth time and it becomes so chaotic that
he can't even run, DeSantis will just be there
for some MAGA people to support him. I don't
think it's going to work. I don't think it's
going to work at all. By the way, here's one
other clip from this event while at the same
campaign event in New Hampshire. DeSantis
says what Trump did wrong wasn't to say,
lock up Hillary. It was to stop saying.
Speaker 4: I remember these rallies in
2016. It was exciting. Yeah. Drain the swamp. I
also remember lock her up. Lock her up. Right.
And then two weeks after the election, I don't
forget about it. Forget I ever said that. No,
no, no. One thing you'll get from me if
I tell you I'm going to do something. I'm
not just saying that for an election, and
there are promises I could make that may
help me marginally politically, that I don't
know that I could that I could necessarily
follow through on. So I will not make that.
Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis is saying the problem
with Trump wasn't that he said, lock up Hillary,
remember? No evidence of crimes, no indictment, no
conviction. What they all were for law and order.
But you have no reason to lock up Hillary DeSantis
is the problem. Wasn't that Trump said lock her
up. The problem was that he stopped saying it and
that he didn't do it. This guy is as dangerous
as Trump. He's exposing it every single day.